texas a mother of 14 facing execution on
wednesday could learn her fate later
today melissa lucille is on death row
for the 2007 murder of her two-year-old
little girl new evidence suggests that
the death may have been an accident and
today the texas border pardons and
paroles is expected to make its
recommendation on the case
lilia luciano spoke to lucille's family
about the possible next step
i have children
and they heard
it hurts for me to lose one of my
children
as the days hours and minutes tick down
to the execution of melissa lucio her
mother true to her own name still holds
on to hope she's coming home
yes i told her you were going home it's
been nearly 15 years since lucio has
been home in 2007 her two-year-old
daughter mariah died detectives in an
autopsy settled on child abuse as the
cause and lucio as the culprit but new
evidence from forensic experts suggests
the bruises were consistent with a brain
injury from an accidental fall down
steep stairs two days earlier as lucio
and some of her children told officers
in child protective services but jurors
never heard from them jurors did hear
what testimony experts now consider a
coerced confession
in an unprecedented move over 100
bipartisan texas legislators have come
together to reach a clear consensus
lucio should get a new trial if this
execution is allowed to go forward i
believe it would severely weaken our
criminal justice system and we're doing
everything we can to lock arms and try
to prevent that from happening when you
push the pause button and let's get this
case right lawmakers implored louis
signs the district attorney to step in
at this point it's not my decision it's
the court's decision to make
lucio's defense filed four requests to
stay the execution signs hasn't
intervened i'm with cbs news i just want
to talk to you and declined to speak
with cbs news
lucio's conviction and now her looming
execution continue to take a toll on the
family it's very stressful
sometimes i just want to
put myself in a hope
and i don't want to know nothing
i that it's reality
lucio has faith someone will intervene
even her mother's hope is being tested
she's very hopeful
are you
well sometimes i am and
sometimes i'm not the d.a
he's got
he's got children of his own
i don't think he would like
that to happen to his kids
the texas board of pardons and parole's
recommendation will go to republican
governor greg abbott today the board
could recommend either commuting her
sentence granting a 120 day reprieve to
give more time to the courts to decide
on lucio's fate or to uphold wednesday's
execution if the date does stand lucio
will be the first latina ever to be
executed in the state of texas vlad
lilia i know uh that uh texas state
representative uh mr leach has said that
he thinks it's wrong there's been
bipartisan support for this thank you
for your reporting